As you can see, there's quite a bit to go over with this course, so let's just jump straight in.
So, Chaos vehicle features. What is a Chaos vehicle?
So, the Chaos vehicles plugin is a lightweight system for performing vehicle physics simulations in UE5.
And it's been built from the ground up and replaces the legacy UE4 system.
Now this gives you increased reliability, so the system supports AsyncTick physics overview mode,
which gives you more reliable simulations and more predictable results.
It has a similar setup as the legacy system, so a vehicle is still represented by a skeletal mesh
and one or more blueprints, one or more wheel blueprints, should I say,
making it easier for anyone familiar with the legacy system to switch to the new Chaos system.
It still uses a physics asset to provide the appropriate collision geometry for a vehicle.
And there's increased flexibility with this as well, because a vehicle can now have any number of wheels,
as well as any number of forward and reverse gears.
It also has some more experimental features that can give you less of a realistic and more like an arcade-like feel.
So, using direct controls for individual roll, pitch and yaw torque,
you can really get something feeling really cool and not necessarily super realistic.
Chaos vehicles also now features a modular system, which gives you real-time construction and destruction of your vehicles.
Now this is only available when using this specific modular vehicle system, which we won't be taking a look at today,
but we will take a quick look at the differences between the two systems so that you can see how each one is used.
So both the Chaos vehicle system and the modular vehicle system have both been designed from the ground up
and can exist in the same project together and be used in tandem.
And the main differences between the two systems are the vehicle's composition and the simulation representation.
So what do I mean by that?
The standard vehicle system bases your vehicle on a skeletal mesh.
And this skeletal mesh will contain all of the different parts of your vehicle, skinned to a skeleton hierarchy.
And that's set up in such a way that everything moves in the correct way and pivots from the correct points based on the position of all these bones.
It's also a fixed topology, so these meshes are fixed, you can't change them.
It uses the physics asset for the collision of the vehicle.
And any animation that happens on the vehicle is skeletal mesh animation, so it's the joints driving the movement of the mesh.
Compared to the modular system, where you're not using skeletal meshes, instead it's a hierarchy of geometry collection components.
And this means that you can add or remove these different components at runtime, giving you the ability to construct or destructure a vehicle whenever you like.
And each geometry component can have its own simulation component to drive its behavior at runtime.
And this means that each part of the car can be doing different things at the same time.
When it comes to the simulation representation, the standard vehicle system uses one component to drive the entire simulation, and it's the wheel controller for wheeled vehicle.
Whereas the modular vehicle system is a collection of separate simulation components assigned to a simulation tree.
Now these modules can operate independently of one another, and any of the simulation components can be added or removed at any point in time.
Thus giving you the construction or destruction ability.
But like I said, you can use these two systems in tandem within the same project.
So if your vehicles have really varied requirements, you're not going to be forced to use just one of these systems.
Because Chaos Vehicles is a plugin, the first thing you're going to need is to enable the plugin.
We also need a skeletal mesh for our vehicle, and along with that we need a physics asset.
Then we'll need one or more wheels blueprints for the front wheels and the back wheels.
In our case we'll be setting one up for the front wheels and one for the back wheels.
And then a vehicle blueprint, which is going to take all of this information and then translate it from...
Which is going to combine all of this information into movement onto the car.
And then an animation blueprint to determine what the car looks like when it's moving.
And the last thing will be a float curve asset.
And this is just going to represent the torque curve for the engine.
So that when we hit the throttle or hit accelerate, the vehicle will accelerate in a manner of our choosing.